[Music]  Kim Kardashian is spelt sexy and skinny  at least that's what her sisters are  telling her what the 37 year old reality  star has been grinding in the gym  sharing snaps of her workouts on social  media and clearly the hard work is  paying off  Kim's younger sisters Khloe and Kendall  can't stop showering her with  compliments thank you I've never seen a  skinnier person in my life this takes  work to look like that amazing Kim even  revealed how much she weighs right now  you guys I'm not that skinny I'm down to  119 pounds  the brunette bombshells fit figure  wasn't the only thing she showed off Kim  and Khloe flaunted their stylish new  haircuts and when Kim isn't working on  her fitness she's working on her  business here's what she told et God I  like planned so far in advance I have so  many exciting things coming out but I  want to like focus and stay in the  moment  I love making products that I use  everyday and that are convenient and  easy  you